I heard you've been watching the squid
game the new squid game that's come out
as well you will that be relevant by the
time the episode comes out I don't think
it's relevant the moment it's not even
relevant now like every wrote it off cuz
it was like the first ever was so [__]
and wish it was it was really bad yeah
well I I think it's just because the
conversation has changed you know like
back back I saw a good opinion on it it
was like you know Back in the Day game
shows used to be about like I'll take my
family on vacation I'll buy them the car
they want now it's like I'm in like
$50,000 in debt and I just want to pay
rent and so it's kind of like the
dynamic of game shows have shifted from
being like an extra amount of money for
people to spend what game shows with the
car what well you know like back in when
you were a kid right You' watch a game
show and they'd be like what are you
going to spend the money on it's like
we're all going to go on vacation
fortune or like Jeopardy I'm I'm going
to get a new car the new you know and
and now it's kind of shifted from I have
$50,000 talking really yeah you think
wasn't the priz is all [__] too like no
they us be some pretty [__] good
prizes back in I I feel like I've seen
compilations of people winning [__] and
they're just like wow thank you well
some game shows but there was always
like Who Wants To Be A you know like Who
Wants To Be A Millionaire that's been
going on for decades I feel like it's
not that black and white I feel like
it's gotten worse but I mean back in the
day I remember most of the time people
just wanted to pay off their mortgage
whenever they' win game shows yeah maybe
this is just my biased like memory but
that's what I remember yeah but I guess
the people don't even a lot of people
can't even afford to have mortgages
nowaday I guess you know like it's it's
a CH I think I think it it it's not all
of it but it's definitely some of it and
then on top of that it's like hey it's
the opposite of what the message of
squid game was yeah but is it fun yeah
you're right it's complete opposite but
is it fun yeah I liked it yeah I should
watch it I I was meaning to watch it so
I could form an accurate opinion on it
um but if you like trash TV I guess I
[__] love trash TV yeah you are a
trash TV corner like Survivor I love I
love Survivor even though it's like a
terrible show uh it's just fun well
what's yours and marti's favorite trash
TV show again no we're not talking about
that I'm going to tell them they like
watching selling Sunset that's such a
[__]
show the thing is like when you're a
parent you have no brain capacity after
9M like I just need to watch the dumbest
[__] on Netflix like I don't care
whatever well the UK has like 15 of
those shows all with like different you
really good at making those shows they
love them one of the most popular shows
on all the [__] time was uh uh it was
like home or away and it was basically
like someone would be like I want to
live in Australia but I don't know if
it's right for me and then they would
show them two houses be like look at
this [__] amazing house in Australia
for this seen this it's in Spain too
yeah in Spain they they had a series for
Australia they had a series for like
Spain and they had the whole thing and
it was like it was always like better
abroad they like I just like the UK and
it it's quite nice really yeah they
never picked a lot of the time they
didn't pick Australia cuz it was just
daunting I imagine yeah probably it's
like 14 hours away yeah it's like
there's nothing there just especially
for a British person yeah yeah well I me
like you know I have no threats
whatsoever when it comes to like animals
or like natural disaster
and then I'm going into Hardcore
Minecraft ESS you know true what was the
was the show uh in UK you have the one
where they show a body
part yeah this blows Americans Minds
when you show it still blows my mind as
well cuz when I was last in the UK I
just forgot that it existed and I turned
on Channel 4 and it was just good old
UK I think it's actually it's such an
amazing idea cuz it like almost
desexualized the human body in a wayt
whil while still definitely using sex
like sexualizing the body to their
advantage because everyone is so normal
and not presented in the way that is
sexy that it's like I I don't find any
of this attract there's like an initial
hook of like oh you get to see a bunch
of naked people on TV and you're like oh
that's clearly just trying to you know
use sex to sell and then you when you
start watching you're just like yes you
know that that critique on her that
woman pretty valid like his left not is
a little bigger it's it's it's really
bizarre cuz you go from watching like if
you watch like you know you you see porn
and then you watch this you're like it's
it's the they're showing the same bodies
but that it's entirely entirely
different and you walk away feeling very
different things from each one but
that's how they get past the show of
showing naked people it's
educational but I think it just stopped
airing it just got it just got canceled
yeah rest in peace I didn't like the
show I just think it's hilarious I mean
it was certainly amazing to show
American people and they were like what
the [__] this is on TV it was aw yeah
has the best trash I'm trying to think
what some really good trashy TV shows I
mean come down with me is also a classic
from that's not trash TV that's just
that's crash that's that's golden
standard that's gold boring no you're
wrong so we got Gregs and now you don't
like come down with me basically you
didn't [__] live in the UK you
[__] I feel like people like to watch
it because they think like oh I would
make it so well you you like watching it
cuz you like seeing people care so much
about something so dumb oh really yeah I
think like you watch people who like
they get really into it they're like I'm
going to [__] vote Sarah down two
points oh we did actually get into it
now I remember okay okay okay it is
actually pretty good think about it we
did watch one season all right UK
citizenship giv back oh which is the one
where they have to get married too oh um
don't tell the bride don't tell the
bride no no no is it that one uh it's
the one where oh the guy plans the
wedding
yeah which is clearly so fake but it's
so hilarious he'd be like I think um my
wedding should be a [__] Ewok theme
so I've spent I've spent all the I've
they would have to spend £10,000 on a
wedding without the bride knowing
anything my favorite episode of that was
like the the dude was like I have a
brilliant idea I'm going to do it on a
pig farm oh yes I remember this one I
watched all of and the girl was just
mortified she was like I'm what do you
expect and the dude standing there like
I thought it was a good
idea [__] idiot I saw one where a
dude uh decided to it's definitely fake
oh yeah yeah a dude decided to put his
wedding in a cave he
heck he didn't know that the mother of
the bride had a fear of caves so she
couldn't so the mother of the bride
could
daughter The Producers were [__]
riding heat with that one I KN they knew
what they were doing was the shittiest
wedding B I know I mean Pig one is the
pig the pig there also a few that just
like were disasters like nothing went
right I'm in [__] Primark buying the
groomsman suits is there any was there
any wedding in that show where it went
right yeah there's a few yeah there's
quite a few are happy yeah they I mean
you know some some of them it turned out
they really loved each other and even
though a lot of things went wrong on the
day it just like everything just that
was always the message of the show feel
good it's it's still feel good I I
wonder I I wonder if some of them got
like actual marriages afterwards or if
that was their real marriage I wonder
don't know I yeah I don't know get a
free wedding yeah I guess you do get a
free wedding
yeah you put it like that damn I'll I'll
play your wedding okay don't worry about
it this wedding is sponsored by
also just or that just been a huge
uptake of just reality cooking shows as
well cuz every time on my Netflix
they're so bad always ex it's so easy to
to film and produce a cooking show it's
not you don't have to get anything crazy
you just get a bunch of chefs and and
get a bunch of kitchens and you're done
just like kitchen nightmare like it
peaked with Kitchen Nightmares and
nothing has even come close to touching
like has has come close to touching that
Iron Chef Iron Chef is watch a few
episodes recently fun just great show
what a great show I haven't seen it what
is it it's the old Japanese kind of uh
you know it's like cooking Battle Royale
they would have two teams battle each
other with like and there would be an
ingredient of the day and it would
usually be like the Challenger Chef
would like step in and then Iron Chef
would have like there'd be like three
different chefs with three different
Cuisines and the Challenger Chef would
have to go up against professional pick
one oh they they give one it doesn't
sound good at all no no but then but
then imagine it's all in Japanese right
so then they're dubbing over the
Japanese the dub the Dub's pretty the DU
is the best and they they they mimic all
of the Japanese like mannerisms in the
do it's so good you like Hasan Hasan
what does this mean he's like well
actually I'm glad you asked Koto s this
is how we do that um and then uh like uh
there's there's like they build story
lines so there was like this one I
watched one recently there's a story
line where he beat The Apprentice and
then the whole Squad came like 50 of
this like like Clan from this family he
was like no this won't do beat my better
Apprentice beats the better Apprentice
like no no no beat the vice president of
the clan beats him he's like all right
well I'll do it next episode you'll face
the boss and it's just like what is this
Pokemon ass writing but it's so funks
it's so goofy Che it out literally Shoku
geki it's yeah it's literally
shuii yeah
it's where are some good Japanese
reality TV oh well there's a fair few
that are pretty good there's one at new
years that I recommend watching oh can't
laugh one they'll can't laugh one and
also they do this I think they were the
first to do it they're like literally
they get like a bunch of panels and I
guess GED is always on it it's the pro
oh kak GI yeah where they do this thing
where every year they'll have they'll
give them like two things or three
things and they'll be like which one is
the expensive and cheap one okay that's
so they'll give you two wines you taste
them and everyone has to pick and then
of course G I think it's rigged a little
bit I don't it might be a little bit G
always gets everything right oh really
cuz he's G he well and and it's to say
like you are the you're like the
immaculate Taste of a human being you
have the perfect most refined taste
they'll they'll do a bit where they'll
be like they'll play the same piece on
like a $110,000 violin and a $10 violin
they'll be like which one's the
expensive one yeah how would you okay
yeah celebrities just guessing but
what's really funny is that like at the
start of the show everyone starts off as
like they have this like subtitle which
is like you're an aade celebrity because
you're just like so refined and every
time you get a question wrong you get
downgraded and the way they treat them
on the show get so starts off like
everyone's like has like you know really
nice like chairs to sit on and like
really nice food and the more you get
wrong they just like at the end of it
you just disappear from the frame it's
really they literally just Ed it's only
on New Year only really good it's really
good even if you don't understand
anything it's so visual as well that
it's it's really fun really good it's
definitely one I recommend and there's
also the one that I kind of like and I
wish that other countries did this was
the you are shimar what is it the oh you
are yeah yeah why why did yeah it's B
basically the show where uh the the the
whole idea of the show is they wait at
like major airports like H Narita and
then they go up to foreigners coming to
Japan and they go oh why are you in
Japan okay and then they go oh I'm doing
blah blah blah and they're like can we
come with you and they basically tag
along with the Foreigner to do what it's
not it's not it's actually today credit
not set up at all it's literally just
like where want us to meet you what you
doing I know because I've been stopped
twice for it I st people filming it
right where people went out so I was
like yeah that's probably that that's
what it is yeah oh wow and so they
they'll just follow a random foreign
person and some some just them going to
their hotel well no no they'll be like
they'll be like what are you what what
are you come to these trips so if he's
like I'm going to go fishing on a boat
in the middle of the ocean they're like
okay tell us when we'll meet you there
and they film that yeah so they film
foreigners that come to Japan only
foreigners but I feel like don't they
just I'm going to go to shya square well
they don't they don't yeah they don't
take people be asking if someone's like
someone like I'm I'm coming here to
compete in the baseball championship
like oh can we follow you and I guess
cuz it's so this is this is the like
Japan doesn't like people filming right
but if you have massive clout with TV
shows I swear you get led into
everywhere I swear they they just walk
into everywhere with this camera crew
right dude the moment you say like oh
we're with NHK TBS any of those
like go right ahead sudden all
this and so they're just following them
there's some really cool stuff to get up
to I'll check that out that sounds good
yeah really interesting my favorite one
of those was like the the guy who had
never tried surfing before came to Japan
to go surfing in Okinawa oh wow and it's
just like you follow this dude and he
just goes all the way to okino and he's
like yeah I've never surfed before but
I'm going to try it here and the entire
time is just watching this guy
struggling yeah that sounds bad I hear
it's not that good it's really it's
really like endearing to watch I saw one
where it was like this guy wanted to
learn he planned to learn to make Tatamy
with like a Tatamy making why would you
want to do that I guess
really I thought I thought it was kind
of neat that and that there was a guy
and it was literally like a 90-year-old
guy like [__] fine I'll I'll help you
do it he's like all right wait how he
how did you learn that kind know but he
was with he was like in this guy's house
for like three months just learning to
make tatami
mats found the one weave like just going
10 levels deep into Japanese I don't
know how they find these D I guess they
literally just harass everyone like what
are you doing what you doing they
literally just go up to everyone who
looks foreign and they just ask um it's
it's always very it's a really fun show
um Japan has a lot of shows that kind of
Pat Japan on the back they're like they
have a lot of food shows about like
everything a lot of the TV shows they
put on on on television Japan are like
about how good Japan is and all the cool
things in Japan we do not have anything
like this in the UK it just does not
exist no I think you do we have some
that are like yeah like historical
things you literally just referenced it
earlier with the show moving to
Australia and like no I'll live not like
that's that's that does not make the UK
look good at all like you could have
such a good life in Australia look how
much more she gets paid she's like I
decided not to move from scunthorp I
like it and know but that makes it seem
like it's just so quaint and lovely here
no the only the only thing that I think
makes the UK look kind of good that like
I don't know they just show off some
nice hes sometimes or the Antique Road
showes like no oh I remember my mom used
to watch Antique Road anti Road show is
a classic Antique Road Show is my
comfort show wait did they have an
Australian version or was it the British
one uh it's that we had both I
originally they so anti antiques are
there in
Australia that's a great question the
oldest it gets is 250
years they bring in something like I
think it's pretty nice like this is a
5,000 year-old Relic from King Edward I
four how did you find this in your
basement meanwhile the Australian one is
like oh that looks pretty nice it's like
yeah my dad made it last week I I saw I
saw an article in the UK uh recently on
BBC news they were like oh yeah family
finds that Gard a a garden ornament was
indeed World War I
shell what it was an active bomb shell
and then the story was some dad some
guy's dad found it on the beach thought
it looked nice painted it red and just
stuck it in the garden and then this is
my favorite bit they're like hey I don't
know how someone found this out they're
like we found a bomb in your back Garden
we need to remove we need to evacuate
the neighborhood they're like no he's
like I he's like he's like I'd rather
I'd rather die than you get rid of this
bomb and so then eventually they
convinced them where they're like okay
we think it's okay to take it out and
blow it up somewhere else Jesus
Christ uh Garden yeah Garden or in UK UK
explosion at this this is what they were
willing to this little red thing I saw I
saw the picture of it and I was like
this is [__] this is not worth it
doesn't even look good what this was a
and how the [__] did they have this the
most bombass looking thing that looks
like a bomb straight up I found that
just lying on the streets apparently
apparently when they had like something
dirty or something they would whack it
to get like the dirt
[Music]
out Jesus Christ and I was like this is
the most UK thing
ever it looks really just casually have
a [__] does never blow you never hear
about like you always hear people
finding
that if it hasn't blown up in like a 100
years it's not going to blow
well odds are it's not going you never
I'd win that was kind of crazy I know
I'd
win well I wouldn't die but I
don't neighbor someone else might
neighbor doesn't have it in him he
doesn't have the ego to
survive